[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi guys so the time has come as you just
saw this is a super exciting time for me
but also kind of a scary one but hey
what is life without a few scares the EP
is finally coming out and I was just
gonna leave you with that little teaser
but I really feel like I should just hop
on the camera now and say thank you to
you all because I couldn't have made it
without your support I already
appreciate every every one of you to
have an EP was a childhood dream
literally a childhood dream so I'm just
over the moon and I am so thankful to
Jamie Aldous at Horizon productions who
made my little ukulele songs sound
absolutely fantastic and I am still
working with him going forward so I'm
excited to see what else we make I'm
also super super super grateful to my
patreon and yes you talk to your patreon
even if you were just talked here for a
little bit you will be getting the CDs
so I'm excited to give you the physical
copy as for all of you who aren't gonna
get the physical copy it's Sookie cuz
it's gonna be on Spotify and Google
music and all those streaming things oh
my gosh it's just gonna be yeah so cool
in the coming weeks I'm gonna drip feed
you some behind-the-scenes stuff to kind
of give you know tease about what's to
come but I oh my gosh I just hope you
like it also there will be a official
music video for sweater coming out on
release day and I've got to say thank
you to jr. done Jacob John Rowley Luke
Matthews Jackson Dunn and Amy bald were
helped me out with that music video and
ultimately just anyone else who has
helped me on this journey
anyone who has listened to me play than
the song
over and over and ask them if it's good
enough and just sing in their ear thank
you for being there for me and for
believing in me and helping me get
through the doubt the severe doubt
because doubt is always around I guess
that's it I'm not gonna ramble too much
but yeah I hope you enjoy it when it
comes out so I guess until then I will
see you around
have a lovely day everything